Brittany's life has also been a wild
adventure but she wants us all to know
that she has back on track you think
company that she can still control
social media okay so I just lost the
four pounds that I've been wanting to
lose but now these are the fruits and
vegetables that I eat to keep it off
Brittany showed off her abs and shared a
diet secret with fan sheets lots of
fruits and vegetables the singer posted
this extensive produce chart and
explained how she uses it to deal with
all sorts of health issues like her
quote weak eyes and stress and asthma
and headaches
Brittany's four pound weight loss video
was just the latest of many by the
singer focusing on her appearance I just
got my haircut and new highlights this
is how I am right now
and I'm skinny as a needle hi guys it's
such a beautiful day I had to come
outside and do a little workout a source
tells e.t 37 year old Brittany has been
incredibly concerned about her body
looking perfect and she is quote
painfully self-conscious and while we're
glad to see Brittany promoting fruits
and veggies what we're all so relieved
she can be just like us are you like
really careful about what you eat um
yeah I I am I like clean sometimes I'm
like I just want a hamburger but when
I'm in real work mode I want very clean
I like just clean chicken and veggies
like that's it my stomach is so
sensitive I have a steak I'll be since
like sick for three days you're kidding
me mhm what about the burger what does
the burger do to you and burgers fine
burgers yeah okay I have the small
burgers from McDonald's
you
[Music]